Speaker 1: Let's hear from
some more people. Of course,
we do this on the Friday show. You can follow.
You can talk to me, as I guess I'm saying,
by signing up for the discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Let's go next to Kevin
from Philly. Kevin from Philly. Welcome
to the program. What's on your mind today?
Kevin from Philly. You've got to
accept my invitation, my friend.
There he is. Kevin, welcome.
Speaker 2:
Hi. I was just wondering, you know, we've heard
recently more stories from Donald Trump. With
grown men with tears in their eyes. Yeah.
Speaker 1: The latest one is like that. The
Santas came to him crying about an endorsement.
Speaker 2: Right. Do you think it's always
possible that Trump maybe just wears
too much cologne or has very bad breath?
That's why women constantly have tears
in their eyes. But listen to the issue.
Speaker 1: I'm as confused as you are as to
why grown men are regularly bursting into
tears around Donald Trump. And maybe you're right
that it's like a cologne type thing. Maybe it's
a bad breath thing. Honestly, though, I think the
most likely scenario is Trump's just making it up.
Speaker 2: All right. Agree to disagree.
Speaker 1: You genuinely think people are crying,
but you want to find the reason why?
Speaker 2: I don't know. We'll see.
Speaker 1: Do you believe for a second
that the Santos cried in front of Trump?
Speaker 2: No, of course not.
Speaker 1: I don't either. It just doesn't seem.
Speaker 2: Make the conversation
happened. Oh, well, I know.
Speaker 1: I mean, I. Well, that's a good
question. Did was Santos ask Trump for? I mean,
maybe the endorsement request was made through
intermediaries. It seems reasonable to. Santos
would ask for an endorsement.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I do wonder if if the primary
does come down to them. There was this commercial
where DeSantis like, was reading a book about the
wall and Trump to his child. And it's just this
this sycophantic suck up commercial to Trump. And
it would be so interesting if that popped back up,
if it was a primary between them just to show like
how like subservient Ron DeSantis was to Trump.
Speaker 1: I'm going to look for that. That's that
sounds interesting. I'm going to. Also,
a few years ago, Ron DeSantis pronounced
his name Ron DeSantis, which I find strange,
the change How you say your name at age 40.
Speaker 2: I think that should make a comeback.
Speaker 1: DeSantis Yeah. All right. Kevin
from Philly, appreciate the call.
Thanks. All right. There he goes.